[Musique]
il y avait longtemps que j'étais venu à
paris 1 pour du changement ça il ya du
changement
étant donné l'ont presque plus d'autobus
20 sur les rues sont aussi mouvante
ben est toujours des parisiens qui
souhaitent plus finaud que les autres
mais un rien guindée - celui-là et
garder une équipe avec 6 points d'un peu
plus tôt a très bien avancé s'était
planqué la figure pas terrain d inertie
au moins alors
les boss thaler s'étaient pressées de
monty maintenant vaincu veut descendre
avant d'aller rencontrer moi tu dois te
raccrocher
[Musique]
alors traversé trois comme ça n'importe
où riant ad - un gros malade tu croyais
gagner quelques secondes m17 coup de
castro et à perdre et un bon quart
d'heure ça n'a pas de bon sens
et alors c'est pas parce que tu es entre
les x présente il faut croire que les
choix ab je vous en prie vous j'ai des
points
il ya pourtant des endroits plus dragué
poubelles à couzeix
mais non mais non pas par la voyons
c'est le côté de la montée saint-hubert
nous regarde c'est ce qui s'appelle se
faire remettre dans le droit chemin
[Musique]
et
ces deux boîtes bon sens tu pourrais au
moins de folie du dos et poilu a claqué
la porte au nez
alala commencé un peu pour voir à
l'abonné eh ben c'est pas péjoratif
comme ça
et tu vois on faire jamais son temps est
précieux
[Musique]